[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars rick and
morty season five episode six treated us
to some thanksgiving in july
with the funniest return yet of keith
david as the president who was now i
think for the first time actually given
a name president curtis
but is there a deeper history between
these two men beyond the times we've
seen them battling on the show
as we play the game of ranking who's the
most exploited on thanksgiving
we really must start with a question
what the f
this is where explained our rick and
morty after show where we compare the
virtue of anthropomorphic turkeys with
things like anthropomorphic pickles
because this is the kind of show that
we're watching and loving
i'm eric boss my easter egg breakdown of
all the details you missed this episode
is coming tomorrow but here i am with
co-host who knows the difference between
18 and at
tommy bechdel that's right i know where
it's 18
all the time baby we're the party 1818
there were so many little one-liners in
this episode
and i think i found a thanksgiving
special i can finally show my nephews
teach them how this country was really
founded yeah that's right
super accurate origin story to the
united states
so much back into 20 minutes uh this
week let's break it down here's what
happened
yeah well not break it down that's eric
voss's job let's recap
what happened uh and that's no cap rick
tries to steal the constitution but
morty accidentally torches it
along with the liberty bell the lincoln
memorial
and he activates the robot assassin
inside of the statue of liberty because
you can
never trust the french as i've always
said i mean i
i never thought we would go to national
treasure as rick and morty pulled open
but to do that and to immediately wreck
everything
yeah perfect beginning it was uh we we
started off with a bang or a ding or a
dong as a liberty bell
that's just you know what leave it in
rick tries to trick the president into a
pardon
by disguising himself as the party in
turkey
i can't even read this without laughing
but both are several steps ahead of each
other
like a great callback to those like
thriller movies where like the two
sides have outwitted each other yeah
either side knows
oh so good the president has ordered a
squad of soldiers
to transform into turkeys they'll have
turkey eyes
to track rick and morty down and
eventually turn
himself into a turkey to join the fight
in the scramble the president's id chip
goes into a random turkey who gets
humanized
and takes over the government with
turkey super soldiers
because of course yeah there's there's a
really fun like uh
rule that i think the writers just kind
of came up with to justify
how they wouldn't recognize each other
the human turkey face blindness yes it's
a real thing
but it turned into like an actual thing
that rick has to like an
arc for him he he rediscovers wow this
is real
[Laughter]
uh they team up to wage war with the
turkey army and
uncover the crypt of the new world
releasing the turkey's ancient enemies
of alien pilgrims
and alien natives the turkeys get
massacred but morty
and rick have to disable the washington
monument in space before it turns all
turkeys into a master race
morty destroys more american heritage
that seems to be his specialty in this
episode
and the president uh kills his turkey
gobble ganger gobble i'm sorry i'm sorry
that i made you
say that tommy i'm not sorry i'm about
to get gobble gang or gabba ghoul
tattooed on your chest and then in the
post-credits scene
the soldier coupe voiced as always in
everything that he does
incredibly by timothy oliphant who could
literally read
an archie comic and make it interesting
yeah still struggles with his wartime
experience as a turkey which if you
unpack it in related to real life is
heartbreaking but
when he's cartoon pecking blueberries
off the floor of a fake grocery store
it's
pretty funny i agree yeah it was uh one
of these things i guess it's kind of a
mix of american sniper
and the hurt locker because this is the
hurt locker he ends in a grocery store
just looking at cereal like i don't know
what to pick
and then and then of course just in case
you didn't understand what was going on
voiceover
this guy thinks he's a turkey i don't
want to pay for his health insurance
i mean that's so messed up but that is
like i've laughed
that's how so many people feel how this
country treats yeah
like you're not like i don't want to pay
for anything for you
which is always good that's always great
exactly i know
uh yeah there was some like we were
talking before the show like just the
right amount of like political
commentary
that like and i do like how the
president for a second like
summer starts to feel insecure about her
hot take that oh yeah thanksgiving is
yeah covering up the history
that's what young people do compared to
genocide yeah it's a summer for a second
it's like uh i don't really
know the full history of this i'm just
regurgitating something i read on social
media
and to be and to be fair they when the
president turkey bribes congress it's
bipartisan that they're willing to he
gets 100
approval so it's not like right this
episode was taking aim at just
republicans
it was saying every elected official if
they're just given a pay raise you could
convince them to
turn the country over to a genetically
transformed
turkey human uh oh boy well i think
there is a deeper history to rick
and the president because this is the
most we've seen the president in a
season before he's kind of becoming a
regular on the show it feels like
i'm saying this now realizing this may
be the last time we see him this season
are they just these three instances
we've seen in this season are starting
to tell us a story about him and rick
that
i just want to dig into a little bit
right um but before we get to that
just a reminder that if you want to help
us make more great content new rockstars
shows like rick explain one of the best
ways
you can support us is to check out our
merch at yorkstarsmerch.com the shirt
i'm wearing is something that you can
buy
on the site we also have some black
widow inspired designs we
still have some loki inspired designs
that you'd really like so uh support
this channel get yourself some cool swag
by going to newrockstarsmerch.com but
yeah tommy what's our what's our first
question coming out yes
so uh as we were talking about and i
think we both have some thoughts on does
rick have a history
with the president that we don't know
about yeah uh so i went back to check
this is the president's third appearance
this season alone he was in the sperm
monster episode
he made a cameo in that decoys episode
uh that was great
uh this is his sixth episode overall he
first appeared in season two's get
schwifty and then season three is the
rick cherry and morty date which
unlike get schwifty really showed the
rivalry between rick and this reminded
me a lot of that episode of just rolling
around fighting underneath
all the the national mall yeah but um
there was that visual cameo in the
season 4 premiere let's not forget an
alternate fascist version of the
president in the photo
but we do now finally learn his name
which is weird five seasons into a show
you don't fully name a character and
then suddenly you do the the newsreel
called them president curtis
and i just think that's interesting
because this whole episode gave us a
deeper understanding of the president's
character
and his relationship with rick more than
we've ever seen obviously they're
obsessed with each other
uh and rick has fooled him before with
the turkey pardon trick it seems like at
least three times before based off of
the photos
you're gonna do it again yes yeah it's
like a trick
and i like you know in the sperm monster
episode rick does try to trick the
president for a second by saying that
all these things like
all the mysteries of the world are based
on these one monsters this one
myth um and it doesn't work in that case
i think the president's getting pissed
off at like stop trying to fool me i'm
not as stupid as you think i am
right uh to me the most interesting
detail is the fact that rick has several
spares of the president's clothes in his
garage hanging up
and applying some past adventures that
have ended with them both without their
clothes or yeah being a spare change of
clothes yeah and that was the case in
the season three finale when the
president shrunk out of his clothes i
think the animators just love showing
this guy
and it's kind of like he's got a gut
just that gut that every
fan yeah he's like he's like they call
it we used to call
players on my football team fat jacked
when they had like
massive ripped arms and like kind of a
decent pack area
and then just a gut and that's like
that's what we called like basically all
the all the like smaller offensive
guards they were fact-checked
i was just fat just to be clear how is
this the first time i'm hearing of this
it's something i buried deep inside me
like sorry
half of the new world it's my crypt of
the new world
now uh there was this one moment this
kind of callback where both the
summer and pres and the vice president
ask why don't you two just [ __ ] get
it over with
like just another example but everyone's
noticing how they're weirdly obsessed
with each other
and then at the end of the episode is
rick and the president see those rival
aliens hugging it out they're both moved
by it yeah i think sincerely
yeah so on the one level obviously this
is just a battle of egos between two men
who are not accustomed to having their
power
checked and questioned you know he's the
president of the united states leader of
the free world and then rick
and as morty pointed out their hatred of
each other and their criticisms of each
other
is justified right like the president
needs rick to make america
exceptional and clearly benefits from
his um his wisdom
and his knowledge right whereas rick
needs the president to you know
guard the wall to keep the lights on so
that he can go on his adventures and
[ __ ] on everything
right i'm looking deeper into this and i
think rick has gotten the president out
of a lot of jams in the past now just
the ones we've seen like get schwifty
because we know this president's
involved in a ton
of hilarious conspiracies like in this
episode spider fbr
the crypt of the new world right um but
back in victoria and more today the
season three finale there were those
murderous twins like there was a lot of
weird creepy history to the american
presidency
and then at one point there's like a set
that they roll past in their fight and
it's the fake
lunar landing set you know so i think
the idea is that the
america in this world uh did fake the
moon landing at some point
but i think rick would have been aware
of that
and what's interesting is later in this
episode when morty is in space
fighting with rick he uh you know lasers
the washington monument and then the
laser hits the flag that's on the moon
so in this world
america still did end up going to the
moon right somehow
right uh they just also filmed their
back up they just also filmed it
is this what which is what a lot of our
uh moon conspiracy theorists believe is
that oh we did actually eventually go to
the moon but the 1969 mission
we did not we filmed that that's that's
the belief uh
it's just interesting that the president
tells morty this office comes with a lot
of baggage and i think part of that
baggage is that
um you know in this animated world
america might have fakes going to the
moon
to win the space race but then later
rick helped america actually get to the
moon with his space travel technology
and that is one
thing that rick holds over the president
why the president hates him so much
right it's because rick did that for him
that's just my theory i think i don't
know if i'll ever get revealed on the
show but that's like my
uh head cam i think that makes sense i
mean i think kind of just what you said
to me
it's just an example of two people who
is like really the only person that
that viewers could grasp on knowing how
rick sanchez is
that could push back on rick and that is
the president the leader of the free
world or so quote unquote the leader of
the free world
the president of the united states
because you know historically as we know
even the greatest most like
vaunted celebrated presidents had
secrets and had things that they did
that were
you know kind of not necessarily
nefarious but we're
not necessarily on the up and up either
no matter how popular the president is
you can go to every single
administration except for maybe i don't
know warren g harding i think he just
cheated on his wife a lot i don't i
think he was they said our lowest iq
president
shout out to the harding family if
you're watching i think like you know
it's kind of a commentary of like these
are two
incredibly flawed powerful men and maybe
the only person that would even give
rick pause
to think about his behavior because this
powerful man could make his life
miserable
would be the president of the united
states and it just shows
how the show how powerful the show
thinks rick is i mean obviously he's
interdimensionally galactically powerful
but when he's forced to play at home
this is the one person that he
even might give him even a second of
like should i do this or how should i do
this
to get away with it yeah agreed and i
think like um
despite the fact that rick could
probably wipe out
the entire us government if you wanted
to in a second like
he still needs them because in the
meantime they can make his family's life
miserable
he created this shimmer over there
they pointed out how much jerry sucks
yeah
and he jerry blamed it on his cooking
like yeah the
very shimmer so much
i'd rather be at my parents you never
said that i know i didn't say it but at
this point it should be implied or
whatever
i'd be more comfortable in my parents
house
he's so good chris oh my god he's
incredible and i think a lot of it
uh our enjoyment why they keep bringing
back the president is like
keith david's delivery of all this is so
fun and the writing
the one-liners they gave him in this
episode i think was a step
uh beyond what they've written for him
before like
it it was a little burst back and get
swifty of where he's like wait can i
control kill people with my mind like
just
whereas here it's like everything he
says he called uh he called rick a fart
dick
and it was just ah it's so stupid but
like
well done you know uh anyway we have
more questions coming out of this
episode that we'll talk about but first
we want to thank some people who helped
us
make it support for ricksplained is
brought to you by manscape the best and
men's below the waste grooming
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels
they just launched their fourth
generation trimmer the lawnmower 4.0
join over 2 million men worldwide who
trust manscaped with this exclusive
offer for you
20 off and free worldwide shipping with
the code ricksplained
at manscape.com based on the coloring of
the blur used to cover up rick and morty
and the president's genitals we're gonna
assume that those characters are pro
manscaping
that's right sanchez would appreciate
the technology of the new lawnmower 4.0
it's advanced skin safe technology gives
us all the confidence in shaving
in our most sensitive parts it also has
a travel lock
a 4000k led spotlight and wireless
charging and if you've been shaving down
there with the same nut trimmer you've
been using on your face
you've been doing it wrong no person
wants to end up with pubes in their
mouth depends on whose pubes to be fair
i mean if it's jennifer love you it's
pubes i'll eat those like it's
thanksgiving dinner
[Laughter]
what when is this this is 1998.
party of five is the number one show on
tv oh my god
um well it's time to get your ball hair
and body trimmer with manscape to make
me time the best time and enhance your
confidence with some nice smooth boys
get 20 off of free shipping with the
code ricksplain.manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping to manskeep.com
and use the code ricksplained
unlock your confidence and always use
the right tools for the job with
manscape
thank you also to keeps for sponsoring
this video two out of three men will
experience hair loss by the time they
turn 35. keeps offers a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door in discreet packaging every
three months
you don't have to leave your home which
might be necessary if the us army is
surrounding your home because you
destroyed the constitution the
treatments are affordable and start at
just ten dollars per month the keeps has
more five star reviews than any of its
competitors prevention is key and
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast and hit
up keeps now if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash ricksplained to receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
ricksplain to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com rick's blade and this
show is also sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness preventing you from achieving
your goals well we've all been there at
some point
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
start communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help it
is professional counseling done securely
online
there's a broad range of expertise
available for clients worldwide
just log into your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor
you won't have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room or look for
parking
better help makes it easy and free to
change counselors if you need to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today so visit
betterhelp.com
ricksplained that's better h-e-l-p and
join the over 1 million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for explained audience get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
ricksplay all right tommy back to the
episode what do you think happened in
new york
the turkey president apparently sold it
to france so what do you think happened
to the statue of liberty assassin
well here's what i want to have happen
i want from now on in this universe or
this this version of rick and morty that
they're living in
new york to be controlled by the french
armed with a statue of liberty guardian
and every time they go to new york it's
like called like new perry or something
like that
sure yeah and they and like they have to
make runs and deal with like the people
that occupy
new york now that may be a little too
world war ii
occupying uh territories in other
countries
and maybe the writers don't want to go
there realistically
what i think is gonna happen is like
many a good uh
episode uh it'll just reset back to
normal for the next thing
probably i mean one thing i want to i
want to see more of
like you know how season two ended with
like the federation
uh taking or like annexing earth
yeah and kind of at the end of episode
two you start to see they have like
different currency
or they're given new benefits as a
result of being part of the federation
and then the start of season three rick
it seems like destroyed the federation
headquarters or the federation of prison
uh and we haven't really explored the
federation benefits
since then but you would think that like
earth is still now aware of other
you know uh advanced civilizations like
just a bit of world building just to
call it back the way that you put the
crack in front of the house or the
graves in the in the backyard
yeah uh like i would love to see little
traces of that like just some of the
signs whenever they go to new york just
like
they're in french now you know and maybe
the assassin is just the statue now
maybe they've deactivated it and it's
just
it's just a robot standing there instead
of uh
and now she faces the city and just
glowers at them
guys are just kind of occasionally they
power up
yeah just kind of like eye is sour on a
little bit just scanning the city for
yes i hate to uh do this to you but i'm
gonna ask you to do a little bit of math
and a little bit of uh
politics here okay could could a person
become president could the president
become president with just
10 of the white vote in the united
states
i love this joke in the episode later
he's like i'm going to need 10
of your baby yeah yes
um i am a a political junkie i sometimes
it filters into
new rock stars here but like i listen to
a ton of political podcasts and i like
follow poster data and i
really get in the weeds of it and this
line like got to me i'm like huh is
it possible like to wear a president
would only need 10 percent of the white
vote well the answer is no
uh in the us the electorate is
predominantly white
uh the white voters tend to account for
two-thirds of the full elector
electorate in a presidential election um
now you can win the electoral college
without winning the majority of white
voters like biden got 44
of white voters uh really the
interesting
dividing line is less about race
increasingly
in elections even though black voters
are hugely democratic
yeah it's really if you want to look at
like
how a white person is going to vote look
at their education level
30 like biden got 54 percent of white
voters with a college degree but only 37
percent of white voters without a
college degree
well i'm proud to be in that 37 i'm just
kidding
guys i'd never be political no college
for me is what i meant the joke is that
i'm an idiot
uh i i mean look as someone who myself
and has several friends
uh who have had to deal with like insane
college tuition
you're not necessarily smarter just
because you went to college well there's
a reason why we'll get that out of the
way i can only do rogue theory once a
month but if i had a college degree i
could do it twice a month
yeah um but i think the bottom line is
you need way more than 10
of white voters absolutely to win the
electoral college very funny line though
yeah it's a funny line and you um i
think the president's line was really
referring to how democrats need
and we're assuming this president is
like based on obama but he has like
plenty of similarities with republican
presidents including trump and bush
he's just kind of a generic president
really right um but
uh i think he's referring to like how
every president
really only cares about like the 10 of
swing voters
in america that could be swayed either
way because things are so polarized now
you know uh the two parties are kind of
locked in their camp
their respective corners but there is
like a 10 in the middle that you
might be able to swing yeah you know so
i think that's what he was referring to
also the fact that like
in the in the line from the vice
president like this whole idea of having
to balance out the ticket
with an old white man in the vp slot
obviously that's what biden was used for
obama's ticket in 2008
and i think the reference uh to
what president curtis was saying to fdr
about try having a presidency
uh like trying having a historical
presidency
uh once facebook has been invented i
think was something similar to what the
line was
kind of implies that he's supposed to be
an uh kind of an obama facsimile to me
right like in the way that like yeah you
know
so much misinformation has been spread
kind of in that
starting with i guess a little bit to be
fair with george w bush facebook was
kind of in its infancy then but like
really well everybody could have a
facebook account by the time obama
became president and that's when the
memes and everything just went freaking
crazy so
we're gonna end with uh i'll i'm gonna
put you on the spot actually yeah
because i had a question about this
whole thing of do turkeys actually sleep
in trees
do they fly in the wild well i can tell
you
i actually know this cancer
i without any prodding my brother rob uh
shout out to him very nice young man
uh has land that he he owns land behind
his house
that he hunts on that have wild turkeys
and he's told me stories
of being like scared out of his life
because
a turkey coming out of a tree at like
four in the morning when he's going to
like
because they hunt deer the deer
population in western new york is so
huge the hunters are very necessary
because the deers are just running into
traffic
and people are dying from auto accidents
so like yeah you know
but i i i mean not that i need to
justify my brother but he's a very
responsible hunter
when he hunts if he kills something he
takes it to a butcher and we eat it you
know for
we'll all you know we we use the animal
we don't just yeah i come from a family
of hunters too i think
people who take this seriously they they
know what they're doing they're not just
idiots out there with machines
that boring disclaimer aside turkeys
have poor night vision so roosting in
trees keeps them safe from predators
uh in the darkness like my brother uh
and the weather
and they only move when it's utterly
necessary so it does they fly up into
the trees and sleep
and then they pitch down at dawn and let
me tell you it's the pitch down i think
that like
traumatized sometimes because you don't
realize how huge a turkey a wild turkey
is
like it just he said it's like uh like
it's just like a
cannon like a giant like boulder just
ascending back down to earth
with flapping wings so here's the fun
fact that people know but i know tom
bechtold knows because uh
again thanks to my brother uh turkeys
are excellent flyers
turkeys are the selling selling vergers
of birds
[Music]
straight up 50 feet in the air just to
find a tree to sleep in
they can escape from predators by flying
at an alarming rate turkeys are
you know i think it was michigan coach
jim harbaugh that said he never ate
turkey because it was a scared bird and
he thought that if he ate the turkey
he would absorb the scared energy of the
bird i think
turkeys are awesome i think you should
eat more turkey
if you eat meat because they're
excellent at escaping
and you know if there's one thing a big
man like me needs it's
better skills than escaping you know
i've always tried to get out of scrapes
and i just got to
turn sideways to get through a tight
turn style i need turkey skills so
that's why this month i'm launching the
tommy's turkey initiative
which by the way i did notice that that
turkey company was named after me so
i'm going to share
we'll leave it there that's it for this
episode of explained uh my easter egg
breakdown
of all the little details you missed
this episode including tommy's cameo
will come out tomorrow
uh tommy and i will be back next week to
react to episode seven
we might be able to get it out to you
early because yes this episode is like
out in the world online already
many of you may have already seen it but
we don't want to like make any videos
about it until it comes out on adult
school yeah
just as occurred to see the people who
don't because the people on the show
like
this content that we put out so we
probably don't want to antagonize them
right for sure uh but stay tuned for
that i'm really excited to talk about
that episode
in the meantime follow tommy at tommy
bech told follow me at ea boss follow
new rock stars subscribe to our
explained wherever your podcast thank
you for watching and we'll close with
our favorite moment of the episode
all american turkeys oh my god they gave
it a voice who is this for we're in
space
[Music]
you